chiedo a tutti ragazzi e benvenute visto
la vittoria di starion simulator 2 che
così va dai 4 ma fa niente siamo con te
per ogni salutano come scorso episodio
chiara di una casta ne sono molto
orgoglioso di come andato così concepito
che aveva fatto due operazioni perche e
l'unica certezza che ora il paziente si
chiamava è no sembra allora solo un
braccio che li hai mai visti in giro
dovremmo fare per prendo io quando si
tratta di lo re che deve proprio
innovando aprendo sempre una siringa
allora qui chiuso bravo premi la siringa
e dal dieta a me perché secondo me sono
io il problema gli estivo richiedere una
cosa eccola qua trovata corso e delle
gambe
ok pensa se è così facile la fine
abbiamo battuto da quindi se consueto
vari livelli e l'area questa volta
invece che tra i partner a frabosa nella
setta per parlare ho visto fare tutti
una volta la sicilia con domani devo
fare tasto per abbassarmi perché sennò
non ha senso e raga io perché tagliarli
braccio così eccolo è andato
occhio perché ho lanciato da 100 che va
bene li metto l'altro di mentolato siamo
già a posto
già due sinistri ma non penso che vada
bene ecco qua
ok il problema è che col braccio no gli
ho messo una glielo messo ben in braccio
è lo so aveva perché non ci sono altri
guarda che lascia capire io come cacchio
faccio a capire quale si stimolano ecco
forse ho trovato metti sempre l'altro
ecco la bravo reni gamestop è però la
braccia a casa
e bello che operano anche la lega a
mettere profondamente rally infinito e
probabilmente tale fattore braccio
quello dovrebbe essere cioè la
cioccolata bellissimo è passato ma cv di
qua dove stiamo andando
ne ho la più pallida idea stanno
parlando stanno parlando veloce facendo
cose molto strane insospettate loro
parlano noi non li stavo pagando ragazzi
ma c'è una fine tanto c'è una storia con
uno rapido e chiaro come il sole invece
ne stiamo pregando che siamo un problema
se devo andare il suo nera sopra e si è
un climbing va bene ha posto grande
persona sia che la gara
eccomi stato sono ventola enormi oddio
non uscivo le norme di riva bellissimo
ti prego no dio bellissimo sa cosa fare
non so premat rizzo se come allora le
devi riuscire alla porta proprio grazie
ok c'è un fusibile questa che c'è la
gabbia che preferisce un tale va male va
ok ha infatto verde si è quindi hai
aperto verso qua io prendo il fusibile
che sia mai che serva ti prendi prendi
ovvero preso che c'è la stessa cosa
anche qui c'è anche qua apri queste non
vanno allora il fusibile cambierò
toglilo allora veicolo dove mai chiamato
a un fenomeno mai visto prima vista
tutto previsto fatto io ti aperta mai
visto kenya e questo non è più non è più
saggio byrne escape from new girl dove
vengono smistati gli organi che privati
sulle braccia che cadono ma cos'è oggi
ovada che è già bellissimo cioè che il
caso è diventato già un simile e tutto è
un horror è un horror i sensi turisti e
tutti i generi insieme c'è la torcia la
prendo
ecco qua ok allora guarda vieni qui
vieni qui perché avevo visto un posto
buio poi è però un problema e puntarla
perché non è quel dettaglio vieni vieni
vivi eccoci qui a parlare di rodaggio
segreto seguiamolo un'altra terza prova
a prenderla anche io che avevo detto
anche tu perché da solo ti giuro che
puntarla un caso di soprattutto questa
mano dell'appunto più addosso gara
eccoci c'è un'altra operazione va bene
che dobbiamo fare adesso manca il
computer ma ve lo aspettate vediamo qui
comunque sui valori però non vediamo
cosa fare c'è una porta aperta con i
suoi allo stesso c'è un tal afar
niguarda questo ho offerto tutta la
parete a posto ecco capitan agosta ora
che c'è conflitto nascosto sicuro eccolo
trovato dove dove era nascosto nella
stanza era discreto che si sono
incastrati lo devi tenere in mano perché
non c'è cosa dovete ma davvero è sì
allora vai vi dico cosa serve e small
intestine e la fininvest in piccole
quello largo l'intestino tenue color
grasso però non ho capito bene come
prendere nel culo tenue né quello grasso
no non so io come si fa i ragazzi alla
di spacco la gabbia toracica queste ore
la casta quello che aspetta quando ne
che arriva qualche big
bene devi cambiare l'ordine di questo
perché sono finiti tutti altra parte la
ragazza facendo sta adesso cercando di
romperli anche che in serata ha posto
ragazzi sta morendo a questo vorrei né
morti né morto né morto prendere
prendete la prendete ora non c'è non ci
sono solo sia vincente serata la testa
c'è ma no più delicato di così mai vista
qualche altro morto e il braccio è
volato a destra e stato bellissimo
riproviamo no io penso di sì i ragazzi
io ho molta paura prima dai la ragazza
ma dai ragazzi abbiamo rifatto di nuovo
tutto che aveva portato anche delle
siringhe gialle
se vuoi provare anche degli organi
all'assistenza di oro mirato scendono
così scendi si tira indietro bravo bravo
l'ho presa toglilo ok ok perdita di
sangue 0 mai
esatto è stato il secondo di tv stesso
giusto ti fai operazione veramente
chirurgico metodico magari a posto gli
ho fatto a più dura del bene la mia
siringa usata benissimo è quasi piena è
sicuramente il dottor house
adesso qua ora dobbiamo dargli queste
due parti ragazzi con calma perché ci
siamo
questo di everel altro ok mi metti prima
io metto prima io che mi sa che questa
fate voi raga io e io non sto perdendo
la partner o meno messo store che offre
un occhio gialla nel caso che si
staccano le braccia come stesse pane era
qualcosa che manca quella in verde sino
all intestino largo colom io che ho
messo io l'ho messo male il blues no
para un piccolo quello piccolo
ora tocca a posto bravo bravo bravo
ragazzo
sto maledetto bob o bastano moriamo più
e fate finire il suo livello
la ragazza è stato meraviglioso è stato
difficile abbiamo preso tutte b perché
l'ha pure riparla tra bastare tanto
lobby voglio vedere se far pagare
qualcosa personaggio giusto per
curiosità perché comunque la prova posso
dire che a parte il fatto che dobbiamo
rifare tutto al bagno e pieno di roba
bellissima odio i ragazzi adesso sì un
sacco di roba c'è la mano da mummia
bellio c'è un'altra ma cos'è ma cosa sto
vedendo mentre io saluto fair e vi
ringrazio per aver visto questo video
ragazzi è stato meraviglioso
non potevo desiderare compagni migliori
di operazioni chirurgiche niente come
sono i ragazzi iscrivetevi al canale
lasciato un bilancio un commento sulla
passata la nostra epica surgery crea
pressioni della ragazza
[Musica]
sì